Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my gosh,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and I'd like to ask you,
we're going to get back to that,
but this is another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where my job is to try to
deconstruct world class performers to try to identify the things that make them
as good as they are at what they do.
And that is a mouthful of a sentence,
whether that is their morning routines,
their favorite books,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And this episode is a fun one because we're going to focus on how to use games
to get more done with less stress among many other things.
And my guest is none other than Jane mcgonigal,
h d one of my favorite peeps.
Jane is a senior researcher at the Institute for the future and the author of
the New York Times bestseller.
Reality is broken subtitle why games make us better and how they can change the
world.
Her work has been featured in the economist,
wired the New York Times on and on.
She has been called one of the top 10 innovators to watch by business week and
one of the 100 most creative people in business by fast company.
Her Ted talks on games have been viewed more than 10 million times.
She knows of what she speaks and in this conversation we dig into everything
from recovering from head trauma to how you can use candy crush saga to lose
weight.
10 if that's not enough.
We talk about how to use tetris to prevent PTSD or perhaps call of duty to
increase empathy and there are many other options.
It's a very,
very cool discussion with a lot of science underlying all of it.
Her latest book is super better and I would like to ask you guys a favor.
I got an advance copy.
I've really been enjoying it and testing it.
And I want to ask you to go buy a copy of this book.
So super better.
It's on Amazon,
check it out.
But what is the premise super better offers a revolutionary and science based
approach for getting stronger,
happier,
and more resilient.
Like I said,
I've been testing it myself and it works not only in my feeling better and,
uh,
that's typically a sort of a morning issue or a late at night issue.
But I'm having more fun in the process.
And as adults,
I think we often lose track of play.
My hope is that this episode will help you to reclaim it.
It's not frivolous.
It can help you get a lot more done with less stress.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation with Jane mcgonigal.
Jane,
welcome to the show.
Thank you Tammy.
I am so excited to finally reconnected,
has been many years and I have enthusiastically watched your sort of your,
your growth and propagation of all these ideas that I hope we'll have a chance
to explore in this conversation.
But I missed quite a lot.
Uh,
and we'll,
we'll get to,
for instance,
just the,
the,
the head trauma I didn't know anything about.
But before we get to the serious stuff,
tell me about your dogs and the names of your dogs.
Well,
I have to Shetland sheep dogs and their names actually reflect pretty good
evolution of my sort of work and interest in game design.
So my,
my oldest dog met Jay.
A girl is named after my favorite video game character from grim Fandango.
And uh,
my new puppy Tsonga who's only two is named after my favorite tennis player.
And,
uh,
I think I,
people ask me about games I'm playing and I'm actually playing more tennis and
video games.
Yeah.
So when somebody asks you for those people listening who are not familiar with
your work,
what do you do?
How do you answer that?
I usually lie actually because
George Costanza style.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I've told,
I've been in like on an airplane,
someone asked me what I do and I tell them I'm a cab driver and they're like,
why are you flying to China and is this fast enough?
I'll say,
oh,
I'm getting an award for being a really innovative cab driver.
I mean,
I,
uh,
yeah,
it's hard to because it's hard to explain to people,
well,
I researched games and I design games and I tried to design games to help people
be happier and healthier and save the world.
And then,
then you spend the whole eight hour flight,
you know,
answering questions about it.
And uh,
well instead of an eight hour flight,
we're going to have a long podcast about all of it.
I'm free to,
can't dodge me with the taxi driver again,
but this time around.
But is it,
am I correct in saying that you're the,
the,
you were the first person to earn a phd studying the psychological strengths of
gamers
and how they,
and how they can apply them to real life.
So I was the first person to really take seriously the idea that people who,
you know,
spend an hour,
a day or more plain,
particularly video games might have some unique strengths,
cognitive strengths,
social strengths,
imaginative strengths that could be applied to real world problems.
And what,
what would some of those problems be in,
of course,
I have some familiar,
familiar already with this because I've,
uh,
I'm a fan of your writing and uh,
I was,
was also a,
an early reader of your first book,
but could you give some examples of what types of real world problems can be,
uh,
either dressed partly,
partially or solved a potentially by,
by gamers?
Sure.
Well,
you know,
I've been working with the Institute for the future in Palo Alto for,
oh gosh,
eight,
nine years now,
and one of my favorite kinds of games to create his future forecasting games.
So to invite ordinary people to try to predict their own futures.
And then when you get enough people predicting their own futures,
you can learn some really interesting trends,
sort of,
it's sort of like a collective intelligence project where you might not be able
to predict what will happen in the rest of the world.
But if I tell you a short scenario,
you know,
um,
peak oil scenario,
you can very accurately predict what you would do,
how you would get to work,
how you would get your kids to school,
what were you,
what you would cook.
And we take all that information and aggregate it to understand how the world
might react to different future scenarios
kind of game.
So now this is a,
this is very interesting.
I mean,
I know that for instance,
uh,
and you could probably elaborate on this,
but whether you're looking at say protein folding,
right?
You could use excess cash processing power from a gaming units to sort of
collectively,
uh,
handle a lot of very computation,
right?
But in this particular case,
are you getting pinged by hedge fund managers and people like that who want to
try to develop investment theses around those types of scenarios?
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
You know,
I was the first game designer to be invited to give a keynote at Davos.
Right.
So there,
there are definitely powerful people interested in these,
although I'm,
I'm happy to say that,
you know,
my work at the Institute for the future,
it's a nonprofit organization and we're mostly trying to help the world,
you know,
survive environmental catastrophe and,
and John makes and things like that.
So uh,
have been used more for more for global good then individual profits so far.
Well,
I did,
I suppose though there,
there could be innocent conversation about how you can utilize both,
right.
Or make them in some,
in some,
in some respect,
a virtuous cycle.
So if you have people who are incentivized,
right,
to help develop games that drive their,
perhaps,
uh,
their own benefit,
but at the same time they're facilitating the development of toolkits or
architecture is or whatever that address these larger scale problems facing
humanity.
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
it is,
uh,
it is a very interesting conversation,
but I don't want to take us too far off topic immediately.
Could you please describe to folks,
and this is as much for,
for my,
uh,
add to satisfy my curiosity than anything else,
but the,
the concussion.
So I,
I'm ashamed to say I knew nothing about this.
Uh,
but could you describe for people what happened and sort of what,
what happened after that incident?
Sure.
Well,
you know,
while it was happening,
not a lot of people knew.
I actually tried to hide it for a long time because I was so impacted by the
concussion that I was afraid I would never be able to work again.
You know,
I was afraid I'd never be able to speak publicly because I couldn't remember
things long enough to put together a talk.
I was in the middle of writing my first book and I thought,
my God,
I'm never going to finish my book.
My publisher isn't going to get,
I mean,
I was,
you know,
I was not,
um,
screaming from the rooftops that a I,
that I was having so many problems,
but uh,
it was even to the summer of 2009 and I was just,
it was just an ordinary day rushing around my apartment and uh,
wound up hitting my head on an open cabinet door.
Okay.
Did you like step up?
Did you stand up quickly like the hip and whack your head or how did you go
about,
how do you do here head?
I did,
I some sometimes people ask me if this was a sports injury and I say yes kind of
because I am a runner,
like a marathon runner and so very strong quads and I just,
I was in such a hurry,
I just use like the full force of my quads power up.
And uh,
it was,
it was crazy.
I mean,
literally it was out of,
out of a movie.
My husband was like joking around,
Oh,
you know,
who's the president?
And the only thing I could remember was that it wasn't George Bush.
I'm like,
I know it's not George who was,
but I couldn't,
I couldn't even remember who the president was.
So that's when I knew,
okay,
this is,
um,
this is bad.
And,
uh,
it,
it was really bad.
So a lot of concussions heal within a week.
But after the first month,
I was still completely can cost.
I mean all day,
every day,
nauseous,
vertigo,
couldn't remember people's names,
lost everything.
I would put something down and never find it again.
Um,
and as I,
I couldn't even really get out of bed.
I couldn't talk to people of his,
um,
it was a disaster.
And,
uh,
my,
my current work,
my new blog,
my,
my new game,
the clinical trial I'm running,
all of that comes out of my attempt to use game design to fix my break.
And the,
this is a,
you did a great job of hiding it for those people who were not interacting with
you on a daily basis because we had,
we had quite a bit of interaction for reality is broken.
Uh,
and while you were finishing that,
so this was happening at the same time that we were interacting.
So,
all right.
So that would be fun to dig up the emails and
see
if they read like Haikus.
Uh,
wow.
You know,
I um,
had very similar experience last year with Lyme disease for I try to keep it
under wraps.
But with,
with respect to the concussion,
can you describe then what followed?
I mean because you,
you had some very dark periods and I,
I'd just love to hear how this work that you're doing now,
at least some of it evolved out of that concussion.
Sure.
So,
uh,
I,
by the way,
I'm like the world's expert on concussions now because I've learned every bit of
research that has ever been done.
So one of the things I learned is that there is a 30 day window for recovering
from concussion.
Most people recover within 30 days.
And if you miss that window,
then they tell you that the next window is three months.
And then if you miss that window,
if you're still having all these symptoms,
then it's likely to be a year.
And if you are still totally symptomatic in a year,
then you may have the symptoms forever.
Um,
and that was something I learned on day 34 of my concussion.
when my doctor told me,
Oh,
you know,
you've sort of sort of miss the first window of recovery of 30 days,
so that's good drag out for three months.
And at that point,
you know,
you have to imagine I couldn't do anything.
Uh,
I mean you're basically on bed rest but you can't,
I couldn't watch TV unless it was episodes I'd seen before because I would get
really confused by the plot.
Like I remember watching an episode of TV and was just like,
who are these characters?
I can't keep it straight.
Um,
so you can't do anything.
You can't go running,
you're not,
you can't drink coffee cause it,
it aggravates the symptoms.
Um,
so I was more depressed and then ever been in my life.
I was super anxious that I would never work again.
And you know,
my husband had just been laid off from his job.
So the only upside of that was that he was able to say at home and care for me.
But the downside being neither one of us was working.
Um,
and so I was just,
I mean,
it's a total mess and sometime in that first 30 days I also,
to make things even more dramatic and awful started to have suicidal ideation,
which,
um,
you know,
just meant that I was sort of hearing new voices in my head.
Um,
you want to,
you should kill yourself.
You're never going to get better.
You're going to be a burden to your family.
Um,
this,
you know,
every day is going to be this awful for the rest of your life.
Just get out now.
Um,
and I did not know at the time how they found out later that this is actually
really common,
the traumatic brain injuries,
that it happens to one in three people who even just from a mild concussion,
one in three people will have suicidal thoughts,
which first of all,
we should tell everybody.
Because when it starts to happen to you,
it's,
it's such a relief to know that it's not your brain actually wanting to die,
right.
That it's just,
it's just the neurochemistry of the brain.
Your dopamine levels are,
I mean zero out.
You literally,
your brain cannot imagine any positive outcomes in the future.
You have no access to dope mean and so literally it is impossible to imagine
anything good ever happening again while the brain's trying to heal.
Um,
so this was like,
this is where I went and I was,
I was basically,
you know,
worried that I was going to kill myself and,
and,
and then my doctor was like,
Oh yeah,
and you've missed the window of recovery here.
So,
you know,
good luck for another three months.
And if,
you know,
it may be,
it will be like this forever.
Um,
so that,
that was,
that was where things went.
That was,
that was rock bottom.
And
how did you dig yourself out of that?
I mean,
what were the conversations or interactions that allowed you to get out of that
hole?
Because there are people who don't get out of it.
Right.
And like you said,
it's important to have these conversations so that people can view it as a
collective symptom and not a personal,
singular individualized flaw.
But how did you,
how did you start turning the corner?
What was it?
There were two key things going on that summer that really helped me.
So the first was I had been writing my book,
the first book,
reality is broken,
uh,
which is all about how games make us happy and there's happiness engines.
And I thought,
well,
shit,
this is this.
I should really,
really,
really tough the series out,
you know,
take this really seriously.
Because if anything could jumpstart my brain into being happy,
even though they'll bring,
was zeroed out and in my brain was telling you I want it to die,
well,
games should be able to do it.
Um,
the other thing that was going on that was,
I was watching,
uh,
rewatching the entire Buffy the vampire,
right?
You just learn so much dork credit.
Yeah.
Because,
because I knew all the episodes so well,
so it wasn't taxing to my brain.
So,
um,
so it was watching Buffy and I just decided,
you know,
I'm going to try to turn this recovery process into more of a game because I
know games make us more optimistic and motivated and,
and it's,
you know,
it's easier to ask people for help when we're playing a game.
Uh,
and it's,
so I decided to just invent this game called Jane the concussion slayer.
And I was going to be like Buffy the vampire slayer who did not choose to be
this layer right feet,
just the rested upon her.
And she had to just step up to the OIC occasion and,
and I was going to step up to my own her vogue occasion and treat all of these
symptoms like demons and vampires and,
and just be a bad ass.
That was a,
that,
and that was a start of a game that I played for the rest of the year and that
now half a million people have played and that we just ran a big clinical trial
on.
So,
um,
it's been,
and that was,
it's been almost six years that that kind of crazy idea has been developing into
something much,
much,
much bigger now.
And I feel like Rip Van Winkle,
I'm so embarrassed that we haven't talked about this before.
I got an early copy of the new book,
which by the way,
I should just say it's super better that I get sent a lot of books and my
assistant sees all of these books.
And this is the first time that she said to me,
uh,
when you're finished with that book,
I'd like you to give it to me.
Oh,
uh,
very,
very fascinating.
And I'm,
I'm already,
uh,
into the book,
which is saying a lot because it's a,
it's one,
uh,
you know,
I get 20,
30 bucks a week and this is the one that I'm focusing on right now.
And,
uh,
it's partially because I want to fix my own problems.
Right.
And in reading the introduction,
you talk about being gameful,
and I'd love for you to talk about that and then also just talk about the first,
uh,
incarnation of the game as you played it for yourself.
Sure.
Well,
I am excited you want to talk about what it means to be gainful because I feel
like this is a really good opportunity to kind of set the record straight about
something that makes me crazy,
which is the topic of gamification.
Ah,
yeah.
I,
you know,
the idea that you can just give people points for doing stuff and that's going
to motivate them and give them achievement badges and that's gonna make them
feel proud.
And it's like a very simplistic notion of motivation and reward.
And I don't do it.
Um,
even though like if you look up gamification on Wikipedia,
it's like Jane Mcgonigal,
right?
He turned,
no,
I never,
did
you see that word in my book?
No,
I don't do it.
Uh,
I like to think of that.
I find when I get motivational speaker and I'm like,
Oh my God,
I've got to live with that one forever.
Okay.
Um,
but so,
so this book is really about something totally different,
which is the game full mindset,
which is a way of approaching obstacles and stress that most of us naturally
adopt when we play games,
when we play sports or we're doing puzzles and board games,
card games,
video games,
almost every single person on this planet and throughout history has been able
to adopt a very powerful mindset that makes us better able to learn from our
mistakes.
More determined in the face of obstacles,
better able to amass resources from other people,
build allies and all these really wonderful things that help us solve problems.
But few of us use that same mindset in everyday life.
Like we only use it in games.
And so that's what I've been researching since my brain heal,
you know,
took about a year.
That's been the new research topic that I've been obsessed with,
which is how do we help people take all the benefits of a gameful mindset,
which mean you're more creative,
you're less likely to give up,
you've got better social support,
you know,
more curiosity,
more optimism,
all these wonderful things.
How do we bring that into the real world?
And it doesn't necessarily mean gamifying anything.
Um,
is it turns out that's the most important thing you can do to really access your
gameful mindset is to play games,
any games that you like and then remember to call on those same strengths in
real life.
So how did you do that then initially when digging yourself out of this hole?
And I think it's,
it's,
it's also important.
Um,
I think a lot of people listening are like,
wow,
like they're imagining sitting in front of a screen playing Zelda or a first
person shooter game or something like that.
But what did,
what did you do concretely for yourself in the,
in,
in the beginning,
and then how has that evolved?
Right.
I mean,
it,
it really wasn't even a game so much as it was a process for being gameful in
everyday life.
So,
you know,
the first thing I did was adopt this secret identity,
right?
Jane,
the concussion slayer.
And the idea behind that is it was just like an Avatar for real life.
You know,
when we have avatars and video games were really focused on,
you know,
what are they good at,
what are their strengths,
how can I level up those strengths?
What are their special secret weapons?
How do they use them?
And we're very focused on strengths and,
and the,
the skill sets.
And so I wanted to start focusing on,
you know,
what are my strengths and skill sets even though I feel completely hopeless and
helpless and like I can't do a single thing,
right?
Um,
to adopt that kind of Avatar for everyday life.
And,
uh,
it was not a digital avatar on a screen.
It was literally me just telling people I'm Jane the concussion.
And as it turns out,
now that I've done all this research,
uh,
literally just talking about yourself in the third person with a focus on your
strengths is this incredible kind of brain hack that,
I mean,
it,
it changes so much in terms of anxiety and depression.
I said that that was the first thing that I did.
So there's this sort of Avatar.
So when you would go like get a cup of tea at Starbucks and they're like,
what's your name?
Miss?
No,
but,
but is this something that,
who would you use that name with?
Um,
you know,
I first started just with my closest inner circle.
Um,
you know,
I called my sister,
my twin sister Kelly,
who is a psychology professor at Stanford University by the way.
So,
um,
I got a lot of good tips from her and,
uh,
you know,
I'm like,
oh,
I'm playing this game to heal my brain.
I want you to play it with me.
I'm going to be Jane the concussion slayer and I want you to be my watcher.
Um,
so I actually adopted the mythology from the Buffy series to give everybody of
my life like a particular ally role to play.
So,
you know,
if you remember Buffy,
her watcher Giles,
he would oversee her training.
So my sister's job was to give me one thing to do every day,
like a little quests or mission,
and then she would call me the next day to see how I did.
Um,
and that was actually amazing because I had not really done anything
successfully until she started giving me missions.
We did stupid things like,
um,
okay.
Can you see out the window from the bed that you are not able to get out of?
Yes.
Okay.
I want you to look out the window and uh,
find one interesting thing.
Like try to see one interesting thing and tell me about it tomorrow.
You want me to talk like spot something kind of crazy outside your window.
Um,
and then,
then I,
then I'll be able to have a sense of purpose for the day.
Like I'm lying in bed with nothing to do,
but I have a,
I have a goal now I have a mission.
Um,
and it turns out,
I learned from all my research later that having a clear goal and being able to
anticipate succeeding in that goal,
that's one of the fastest ways to get the dopamine back cycling through your
brain,
which is,
which is key to reversing depression.
Um,
so,
uh,
so even just being given a little tiny class,
it's like you just like a,
it's a good,
it's a good role playing game like world of Warcraft.
He has here's somebody comes up to you and says,
I have request for you.
Do you accept it and you and you agree to do it.
Um,
that's like,
that's also like a brain hack where you're just,
um,
spiking the Zopa mean levels and learning to anticipate success again.
Well,
that's a,
you know,
I've,
I've been thinking a lot about
resource allocation that's the most boring lag it possibly put it.
But I've been thinking about how people allocate different currencies,
right?
Time,
income and so on.
And uh,
looking at the difference,
for instance,
between buying possessions or experiences and the,
the data very strongly support the psychological superiority of buying
experiences,
generally speaking,
because the value of a purchase decreases very quickly.
I mean,
it's,
it's like driving a new car off the lot and suddenly it's depreciate it 30%.
But when you plan,
and I experienced this last year for myself,
when you plan a and let's say a trip six months from now,
you have those six months of anticipation.
And I recently took,
uh,
took my family on,
on our first real family outing and many,
many,
many years,
uh,
and the,
we went to Iceland,
but it was something that we planned for Christmas and new years and we had a
good five or six months to look forward to it.
And it w it just made all of the bumps along the way,
uh,
c minor and,
and,
uh,
very easily overcome.
So putting that and it just gave us some,
some North Star to look towards when the going got rough.
Right.
So what other,
what other aspects,
uh,
or what other features did you,
did you build into your life?
So you had your sister.
All right.
So secret identity,
you have allies that you recruit and then you have these quests that your allies
give you.
Um,
we also collected and activated power.
So,
uh,
in this,
in the system power ups or anything,
they give you a quick burst of a positive emotion.
Um,
any,
any feeling at all.
It could be pleasure.
It could be,
you know,
laughter can be delight,
whatever.
And so I started collecting,
you know,
like cuddling with my dog for 10 minutes.
Um,
what would be a power up or,
uh,
listening to,
like a powerful song that made me feel powerful or eating walnuts because that
was supposed to be good for bringing healing.
And so just trying to identify things you could do and Justin like a minute or
two to create a positive experience.
Um,
which,
you know,
having a traumatic brain injury is kind of an extreme example of needing power
ups because you otherwise literally you just lie there in a state of abject just
boredom or frustration.
Um,
but making sure that you have these tiny moments of positive emotions.
Because as I've learned now in all my research,
um,
happiness and success and in good health can coexist with all kinds of negative
emotions.
And you don't actually have to get rid of your negative emotions to be really
successful and thriving.
You just have to balance them out with positive emotions.
So the most I was like happy and successful people actually have more negative
emotions then people who are depressed or anxious or or struggling,
um,
they just managed to balance them out with even more positive emotion.
So these power ups are just a way to kind of gain the math.
Every time you feel something really bad,
you try to do a couple of quick things that will make you feel happy,
right.
To offset it,
to tilt the balance in your favor.
And,
and how's that?
What is the current game look like?
Uh,
when you have people,
for instance,
seeing measurable improvements within two weeks and even bigger improvements
between four to six weeks have hundreds of thousands of people who've played.
What is the current state of that game or the format?
So there's a website and there is an app and it's a,
again,
it's not a video game.
It's,
it's like a life management tool where we walk you through the process of,
Hey,
do you think you might have a secret identity?
Here are some ways that you can investigate it.
You know,
we,
we have you think about who your heroes are,
your favorite fictional character is,
are what your strengths are.
And until you are able to craft one,
we ask you to collect power ups.
We,
we find out more about you and we say,
Oh,
you're trying to lose weight.
Okay here are 10 power ups that we validated to be really helpful for other
players.
Or here are 10 bad guys that we know that people who are struggling with anxiety
that also struggle with and strategies for,
for wrestling with them.
So we have bad guys also.
And so we just kind of walk you through the process of looking at your life as
if it were a game.
So it's almost like you're the game designer.
You craft your secret identity,
you pick your power ups and define your bad guys.
And,
and you eventually create your own quest and get the help of your own allies,
who you invite.
And we just sort of teach you the process of thinking and living like a game
designer by offering you,
here's some,
here's some sample powerups and bad guys in class to get started.
Okay.
And let's,
let's,
uh,
let's talk about,
I mean,
I'm going to come back to the power ups because I think for those people who
haven't played games,
uh,
it might be easy to dismiss these things as childish,
but I have,
uh,
did some personal experimentation today,
which was,
which was pretty fun with some of your exercises.
But let's,
let's talk about some games that people might be familiar with.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
the candy crush saga,
right?
Yes.
And,
uh,
so I've,
I've read you are,
I've,
I've noticed that candy crush saga has been talked about is being used to lose
weight in some cases.
And I wanted to just hear you elaborate on that.
So this is amazing.
There are so many games now that people are playing every day and have no idea
that they're powerful life changing tools.
So kindergarten saga has a half a billion people have played this game,
uh,
and like 0.0,
zero,
zero.
1% of them know that there have been these clinical studies showing that a game
like candy crush saga can reduce cravings for things like food or cigarettes by
25%.
Um,
which sounds like not a lot,
but it's actually been shown to be enough of a reduction of the craving that you
can make a better choice as a sort of gives your willpower a fighting chance.
And uh,
the way it works is the game is so visually intensive,
right?
So a game like candy crush saga or bejeweled or Tetris,
the kind of games where when you walk away,
you see the sort of visual flashbacks,
you see the blocks falling or you see that the pieces swapping,
um,
they occupied the visual processing center of your brain so that you can not
imagine the thing that you're craving.
And it turns out that cravings are very visual.
If you've anyone who's ever had a craving knows you,
imagine what you want and the more that you've see it in your mind's eye,
the more irresistible the craving is.
So it turns out you can just get your brain to stop picturing it and obsess it
with some other visual process.
You can block cravings,
not just while you're playing,
but afterwards because he's games have been shown to create this kind of visual
flashbacks.
Your brain thinks it still needs to keep working on this problem because you
were so focused on it.
So your brain is going to keep working on this visual process and even hours
after you've walked away from the game does that can last you three,
four hours.
You've played just for 10 minutes,
but your brain is no longer obsessing over the thing that you were craving a,
it's,
it's like,
it's fascinating.
They're like so many studies like this.
This is one of the reasons why I want to try it.
The book,
and you,
Tim,
you actually inspired me because when,
you know,
when I read the four hour body and you were like,
people,
there's all this amazing science and you should be experimenting with it in your
own life.
And you know,
that's,
that's kind of where game research is now too.
It's,
you know,
people still have a little bit of skepticism and,
and rightly so because,
you know,
we haven't tested the candy crush saga diet over 10 years with,
10,000 people.
But it's so easy to task in your own life and with no downside,
most of these games are completely free to play.
Um,
and so I'm just like,
wow,
people should be experimenting with this in their own lives because studies
there are,
you know,
I think this book sites a thousand peer reviewed scientific studies.
So there is a lot of research.
Um,
we just need to help people get their hands on it.
So,
well,
thank you for the foreign body,
uh,
kind words.
I appreciate that.
I mean the,
uh,
I,
I sometimes push it so far that,
you know,
I hope it serves as a cautionary tale to others,
but a,
you know,
I'm like,
well,
let me be the guy who's a,
you know,
it's sort of getting himself perfused in,
in any number of ways so that you don't have to be that person.
But the,
the candy crush Saga Diet,
let's talk about that.
Or let's just,
let's say,
you know,
you smoke when you go out and drink and if the effects last like three to four
hours,
does that mean that a potential prescription would be to play candy crush saga
for say 15 minutes before you head out for Friday night?
I mean,
is that that the way that it might be used as an intervention?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
and that's,
that is a reoccurring finding in a lot of these studies is that a short dose of
play can provide this kind of,
uh,
these preventative benefits for hours or even one of the studies I write about
in the book two hours of game play,
change the players' behavior for three months afterwards.
Um,
yes,
I don't know if you've gotten to the chapter yet about the cancer patients who,
um,
we're,
we're better able to take all their chemotherapy medicine because they played a
video game.
Have you?
Oh,
the game is called remission.
Um,
and yeah,
and uh,
there's actually SQL that's out now too,
which is awesome.
And they're all free to play the remission games.
So if you know anybody,
anyone who's listening who has a friend or family member or is battling cancer,
this game has been shown in a clinical trials to improve,
um,
the patients,
first of all,
optimism and self efficacy.
They don't feel so powerless in the face of cancer,
but also to increase the doses of chemotherapy that they're able to,
uh,
take when you're,
if certain kinds of cancers like leukemia,
you have to take these pills for two years,
three years at home,
ongoing basis.
Um,
the following kinds of side effects.
And,
uh,
almost,
more,
more than a third of patients miss a significant number of doses because of the
side effects are because it's really hard to never miss a pill on schedule over
two to three years.
Um,
but they know that more than 80% of cases where the cancer comes back is related
to miss doses.
So if you can get people to not miss any doses,
you have dramatically improved their recovery outcomes.
And then,
so this group called hope lab in Palo Alto,
uh,
created a game designed to basically,
they didn't know what they were doing,
but they basically hacked these patients' brains to change how they viewed
themselves and how they viewed chemotherapy so that they started to view it as
empowering rather than something that made them sick or that they hated.
And it was able to hack into their hippocampus and the cottage and Thalamus,
which we know are related to motivation and not giving up.
And they know this because they did brain scans of the players and had them an
Fmri machines and looking at their brains while they played the game.
Um,
so they could see what was actually going on to change their behavior over a
three month period.
Um,
but the upshot is that,
you know,
when they measured their blood,
um,
three months later,
the cancer patients who had played remission for as little as two hours had 41%
more chemotherapy medicine in their bloodstream and they had missed 18 or 19%
fewer doses of antibiotics as well,
which they use electronic pill cap monitors to measure.
Um,
and uh,
and,
and that was over three month period,
two hours of playing the video game.
Um,
this is a big clinical trial they ran with dozens of hospitals around the United
States.
Um,
so it,
it's amazing that these games exist.
Um,
and that I think,
I think something like a quarter of a million cancer patients have,
have been given access to these games now,
but you kind of want every cancer patient to get access to them.
Right,
exactly.
That's the thing about games as treatment.
There is extremely little risk of negative side effects or a kind of opportunity
costs you cause you can do a game alongside traditional therapy for depression
or if you know,
you feel like you want to,
you have some kind of pharmaceutical solution that you're pursuing games really
at no downside.
Um,
and all upside.
Let's talk about just a couple of other games.
Tetris and call of duty.
Can this be used in any particular way?
Yeah.
Tetris.
Oh byway.
So exciting because literally yesterday a new study came out about Tetris that
validates the studies that I write about in the book.
And I was so excited because people have actually been a little bit skeptical
about when I encourage people to play Tetris to help prevent post traumatic
stress disorder.
I wish I will now explain how that works.
Uh,
people are like,
oh that could be really dangerous to tell people to do that because what if they
never see a therapist because they think they've cured themselves with tetris.
Right.
So,
cause you always have to preface this by saying,
if you're having problems,
you know,
you should see a doctor or a therapist.
But um,
it turns out that if you play tetris within six hours of witnessing a traumatic
event,
so they've only tested it on witnessing trauma rather than,
you know,
you yourself were traumatized directly.
Um,
but if you,
if you play Tetris for 10 minutes after witnessing a trauma,
it prevents flashbacks and lowers symptoms of post traumatic stress disorder
afterwards.
And it's really actually very similar to how the candy crush Saga Diet works.
Um,
in that visual.
Exactly,
exactly.
It prevents your brain from kind of a obsessing over what you saw.
And what's amazing is this new study that just came out this week shows that if
you miss that six hour window,
because it's one of the reasons why people were skeptical was who's going to
remember to play tetris within six hours of a trauma.
Um,
even though I've been doing my best to kind of create public service
announcements so people know,
kind of like stop,
drop and roll.
If you catch on fire,
you remember that stop,
drop and roll.
Right.
So I'm trying to,
I'm trying to like drill into people's heads,
you know,
play Tetris,
don't replay the trauma,
like play,
don't replay.
Um,
if you were like,
nobody's going to remember after trauma to play.
So now they have found out that you can actually wait 24 hours and if you re
stimulate the memory,
you ask somebody to visualize the trauma that for just a minute or two.
So it's kind of fresh in their brain.
The brain is accessing those memories and,
and dealing with them directly.
And then you go play Tetris for 10 minutes.
You can kind of,
you're not erasing the memory overriding it.
Well it's,
it's interesting.
So this is super critical detail.
You can still recall the experience if you're asked questions,
you can remember details of the experience.
So it's not like the,
it's not like I'm eternal sunshine of the spotless mind.
You can see you can silver member,
but your brain is not forcing you to think about it when you don't want to.
So it's voluntary recall only.
And so this new study shows you can wait 24 hours,
prime yourself by thinking about it and then play touches her 10 minutes right
afterwards.
Um,
and then that reduces the flashbacks and PTSD symptoms as well.
And they think,
you know,
if it can work after 24 hours,
that this might be able to work with people who have been suffering for months
or year.
It's with flashbacks now too.
Um,
which is,
which is amazing because it is literally the hardest to treat symptom of post
traumatic stress disorder.
And when people get flashbacks under control,
their quality of life improves immeasurably.
Hmm.
And uh,
call of duty call of duty was,
he's like a,
they're like a million things.
That call of duty,
um,
does really well,
you've already covered some of that on a previous podcast.
I know you were talking about sort of cognitive enhancement benefits.
So Adam [inaudible] who's amazing and I love,
I love his work.
So we won't talk about cognitive enhancement,
but call of duty can,
uh,
well the first thing you can do is it can really improve relationships with
people if you play in the same room with them.
So there's,
if you can actually be physically in the same space with somebody playing with
them because,
uh,
it dramatically increases mind body synchronization.
So what that means is if you were playing call of duty with someone in the same
room,
um,
you start to sync up with them at every possible level.
Your breathing rates,
you'll start to breathe in and out at the same pace.
Your heart rate's will synchronize.
So,
um,
their pulses are,
are kind of equalize.
Your facial expressions will start to mirror each other.
Your body language will meet each other and your brains will actually,
they will start to show blood flow in the same region and the same tempo as each
other.
They call that mirror neuron effect.
Um,
and it happens,
it actually happens in basically all video games.
But the more intense sort of high speed,
fast action intensive the game is,
the more it happens.
Um,
because in order to do well on a game,
whether you're competing against someone or collaborating with them on the same
team,
you have to be able to anticipate what they're going to do next,
right?
So that you can either cooperate and be effective or so that you can outmaneuver
them and beat them.
And that that forces your brain to try to mirror what their brain is doing.
And as soon as your brain starts to mirror each other,
everything else starts to marry each other.
And it turns out this is like the building block for compassion and love.
So basically you love people more when you play call of duty with them,
but only only if you're in the same vertical space.
Yes.
So something which is usually we'd spend,
I mean,
most gamers are,
you know,
playing with people remotely and it just ends.
Um,
but if you can get in the same room that has this really magnificent Ben,
right.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to take a,
a digression into what might be an urban myth or it's not really an urban myth,
old wives' tale,
not also not totally appropriate,
but you are,
you have an identical twin,
is that right?
Yes.
Do you have you the two of you experienced anything that's kind of like spooky
accident action at a distance?
You must be sick of this type of question,
but I'm really curious.
See,
now you're going to like,
I have to,
you know,
I'm really into science,
so I'll now I will say something that will sound like,
oh,
you know,
mystical.
Spiritual.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I add a caveat just to,
to make it easier?
Yeah.
I believe a bunch of stuff that seems quacky or than the quirkiest of crack.
I mean it,
but it's from empirical firsthand experience.
And just because we can't explain it doesn't mean we won't be able to explain
it.
Yeah,
no,
I think there's actually probably some,
you know,
the,
in physics they talk about these,
uh,
like you can have the twin,
a fact like protons will be separated but then still be able to communicate at a
distance,
like,
you know,
a billion light years away from each other in the galaxy.
Um,
so maybe the fact that we were once the same egg,
we are identical twins,
you know,
and we maybe,
maybe we have some weird spooky twin effect.
Um,
so yeah,
I call it twin infection cause it only works if,
if something really horrible is happening to my sister.
Uh,
so I will like I will,
it was almost like I'm having a heart attack.
Am I forgot what a throw up my,
like I can't breathe.
I feel like I'm being attacked.
Um,
and it just,
it happened to a couple of years ago during a really emotionally traumatic time
with this is the most reason it doesn't happen all the time.
It really only happens to something truly horrible as it's going on.
Um,
and I was like,
oh,
is that a,
I was at a store in Los Angeles and I like fell to the floor in the dressing
room and I'm like,
what's going on?
And then literally two minutes later,
you know,
my sister called me sobbing,
like the worst pain I'd ever heard her in.
Um,
it was,
uh,
two wins dealing with a death in the family.
And I was like,
okay,
well that explains what just happened because uh,
you know,
we were,
I was having a twin faction.
Wow.
And you,
you,
you have a pretty twin rich life at the moment.
I have little twin baby.
I have my own little twin girls.
And are they identical or fraternal?
They're fraternal.
So it'll be a totally different experience because I think,
you know,
having someone with the same Dna,
it feels like your life is an experiment.
Like whenever she does anything amazing,
I'm like,
why?
Why am I not doing that?
We're like the same person.
I should be able to do that too.
Cause I think fraternal,
it's less pressure,
I think
for less pressure,
but there's still something there.
I have relatives who are fraternal twins.
There's still,
there's still some unusual connection there.
Uh,
but I don't want to take us too far off the reservation here,
but I am fascinated by this stuff.
And uh,
you know,
in partially get us reading the,
uh,
at the beginning of,
of the book,
the new book,
the Subaru read her book.
And there were a couple of things that jumped out at me.
The first was in effect,
let me just find it here.
There's a line that reads.
But even when I still had the symptoms,
even while I was still in pain,
I stopped suffering.
And I think this is really important concept because lush sheriff this from the
military or elsewhere,
but I've,
I've heard,
uh,
pain.
Pain is mandatory.
Suffering is optional,
right?
Or,
or pain is inevitable.
Suffering is optional,
which is a Buddhist saying,
oh,
well there we go.
Maybe the Buddhists,
military from the Buddhists,
special operations forces.
So,
so cute.
I think this is really important because like you said,
it's not necessarily about eradicating all negative experiences,
which is not possible.
Uh,
but about increasing,
if you have two bank accounts,
one of negative experiences and one of positive,
you just want to make sure that the balance and the positive is higher than in
the negative.
Uh,
could you talk a little bit about post traumatic growth?
Sure.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
the idea of a gameful mindset is that it's exactly that,
that you look at pain as inevitable,
but,
but suffering is optional because if you think about when you play games,
you're always trying to suffer.
When you play games,
like games are voluntary suffer it and you think about golf,
you know,
uh,
if,
if in real life your goal were to get a small ball and a small hole,
you would just walk up to the hole and you would put the ball in it and you
would be happy with the outcome.
But you volunteer to suffer by standing really far away from the hall,
which is a stupid way to achieve the goal.
And then you use like the stick to try to aim the ball,
which is also pretty inconvenient.
Um,
the every game we played like scrabble the same way,
you know,
you don't get unlimited letters,
you only get the seven letters and we're going to,
you can't even pick them yourself.
So it's like,
it's,
it's a voluntary suffering.
Things are harder than they should be.
And that's what unleashes the creativity and the curiosity and the optimism and
the recruitment of friends and resources.
Um,
so,
uh,
the gameful mindset is really about how do you look for voluntary obstacles in
real life.
How do you look at things that you are currently experiencing as suffering as a
instead a way to get stronger or happier.
And then that's where the idea of post traumatic growth in which is not,
not all that new field of research now that was probably a decades worth of
research now showing that many people who undergo a traumatic experience,
uh,
in addition to suffering.
And by the way posttraumatic growth,
it's not the opposite of posttraumatic stress disorder.
That's a misconception that the many people sort of stumble onto.
Um,
most people with posttraumatic growth,
first experience,
posttraumatic stress disorder.
So it just because you have one doesn't mean you can't ultimately wind up with
growth.
Um,
and it,
it's a process where by wrestling with these really difficult things,
you get to know yourself better.
So at the end of posttraumatic growth,
you feel like you understand your strengths better.
You feel like your friends and family understand you better.
You feel like you,
you know your priorities in life better and you have more courage to make
decisions so that you're putting your time and energy on the things that matter
most to you.
Um,
it's kind of similar in that way to a near death experience.
A lot of people have near death experience.
Suddenly they relish every day.
They're not afraid to speak their minds.
They,
they,
they really do put more time on their personal dreams or spending time with
friends and family.
Um,
so posttraumatic growth is the same way,
but you only get it by really wrestling with this incredible,
almost existential crisis in your own life.
Um,
which for me was the traumatic brain injury and not knowing whether I would ever
work or,
or really be myself again.
But it can take the form of,
uh,
setting a goal like running a marathon or fill in the blank.
Right?
Clo yet this is,
so this is,
there have been now a couple books about post traumatic growth,
but I am happy to say that I have the first book on post ecstatic growth,
which is a concept that was originally discovered by this amazing researcher and
Marie rip key at University of Pennsylvania.
Not a lot of people are familiar with her research and I'm hoping this book will
shine a spotlight on it.
She found that many people seem to be exhibiting characteristics of
posttraumatic growth by doing things that they had chosen for themselves and
that we're not,
you know,
traumatic experiences per se,
although there might be trauma involved.
So training for a marathon,
becoming a parent for the first time,
starting your own business,
going on at kind of spiritual journey,
look like a physical Mecca somewhere.
Um,
things that are really challenging that you will probably fail at at some times,
you know,
make mistakes,
struggle.
Um,
and that really force you to cultivate that same understanding of your own
strengths,
reaching out to friends and family,
taking stock of your priorities.
Um,
it turns out you can have all the benefits of posttraumatic growth without the
trauma,
which is amazing.
Yes.
And so that's,
that's why you know,
this super better method is basically a roadmap to post traumatic growth.
If you have an illness or injury or your life is pretty good and you still want
to get all these amazing benefits,
helping you define for yourself a challenge that will be meaningful and,
and difficult enough but also doable that,
that you can get to these benefits.
I've to one observation and then,
uh,
then,
that a question,
the observation when I was reading this and also just listening to your
description and talking about for instance,
the posttraumatic growth following a near death experience,
um,
which is of course not something that you,
a,
it's dangerous to try to engineer near death experiences in the literal sense.
Although a lot of people do,
right.
I mean there's,
you know,
people,
people pursue extreme sports and things like that because of that,
that ability to really see so clearly what you want out of life,
you know?
Well,
it,
it magnifies,
uh,
in really exaggerates,
oh,
a lot of the emotions and provides clarity in those moments in some cases.
And I couldn't help but think about a,
a,
the,
the wife of a friend who used to work in hospice care and she would palliative
care,
she would sit with people in the,
in the weeks and then moments before they passed on,
before they died and she wanted,
she,
it turned out she was basically a Michael Jordan in that capacity.
She was really good at guiding people through that.
But,
uh,
she wanted to have the opportunity to help more people and she ended up then
working with,
uh,
psychedelics to help people
simulate that type of near death experience.
And I don't,
we don't have to take,
uh,
we don't have to go far down this road.
But I mean Ha,
I've had conversations,
for instance,
on the podcast with the Jim Fadiman who talks quite a lot about micro dosing,
but also the use of higher doses for these,
what some people would call it spiritual or mystical experiences.
Yeah,
it's,
well,
this is actually very interesting because,
you know,
when I was at Berkeley doing my phd,
I actually wrote a research paper on the commonality of experience of people who
are playing these certain types of games,
these kind of very collaborative collective intelligence games and these
spiritual drug taking,
uh,
you know,
like the psycho knots they call themselves.
Right.
Um,
a good place.
I've actually,
because we get,
so that's something I've actually been interested in for,
you know,
a very long time because there is,
I do think there is a spiritual element to a lot of game play in that,
that sense of really wanting to open yourself up,
um,
particularly in an end games that require,
you know,
to be a part of a massive community.
And part of these kind of epic narratives,
um,
like you know,
Joseph Campbell's Hero's journey.
Um,
there,
there is definitely a spiritual element to that and a lot of spiritual benefits
that come out of Gameplay,
which,
which is,
you know,
maybe that I might,
for my third book,
I keep saying I want to write a book called Super Mario was a Buddhist.
So maybe,
maybe,
maybe we should come back to that.
Uh,
if for episode 800 of your pocket
Super Mario was in the Buddhist special ops as we've,
as we mentioned earlier.
Yeah,
no,
I actually,
I actually got to go to a Buddhist conference and give a keynote with like all
the most important Buddhist in the world were there and actually gave a keynote
called Super Mario was a Buddhist,
but it had a question mark after the title because I was,
that gives,
it gives you an out if there's a crowd mutiny of the crowd.
Exactly.
So Games I let,
let me,
uh,
it has like to ask a personal question and this is because I,
I love playing games.
I was a,
I was dungeons and dragons aficionado slash obsessive growing up and that was my
refuge.
I mean I was,
I was a real kind of runt dork growing up and got beat up in elementary school
and whatnot.
So I used games as way to escape but also as a way to,
to live this sort of virtual life that enabled me to I think in many ways
develop characteristics I wanted later in life.
Right.
And,
um,
but when people ask me now like,
oh,
are you a Gamer?
I don't know how to answer that because when I look at how slick the Games are
that have been developed and how much money has gone into developing games that
are as addictive as possible,
I,
I choose not to play those games out of fear.
And the fear is the same fear I would have if I tried heroin people,
you know,
if someone asks me like,
if you tried heroin,
I'm like,
no,
I haven't.
I'm sure I'd love it.
And that's the problem.
Like,
I don't want to become a heroin addict.
And I worry about becoming one of these people who say sinks 40 to 60 hours a
week into world of Warcraft.
Cause I know I have that capacity.
Right.
Yeah.
I know it's there.
So how,
what are ways that people can reintroduce yup.
Gameful mindset or gameplay.
Yup.
Let's just say it's a,
somebody who's working 80 hours a week and they recognize,
they're like,
you know,
I want the joy and all of the promises of a gameful mindset and or Gameplay,
but I don't want to go off the deep end and end up becoming completely consumed.
Yeah.
We know I can really relate to this by the way.
You know,
I,
people ask me what my favorite games of all time are and I always have world of
Warcraft in the top,
you know,
three or four if think of the best games of all time.
But I only played it for a very short time because I saw what my future was
going to be like if I didn't get out quickly.
Um,
and I was my husband,
I,
our plan is,
you know,
when we're retired and old and maybe unless they've invented extension
technologies so that like at 150,
we're running around like a 20 year old,
assuming old age is similar to how it is today.
I'm going to be totally addicted to these games when I'm like 90,
because it'll have all these cognitive enhancing benefits and I'll be socially
connected to other people.
So I'm,
I'm waiting to get addicted until it really is better than,
you know,
trying to live my old life.
Um,
but,
uh,
there's lots of things you can do and I should just say also as a sort of public
service announcement benefit,
one of the things that I write about in the book,
um,
there is a chapter,
an entire chapter on what makes a difference between somebody who benefits from
playing games and brings a gameful mindset to real life.
And somebody who develops some kind of addictive or pathological or compulsive
gaming behavior.
And there are two things that predict whether you will benefit and be gainful in
real life or whether you will kind of get addicted and the rest of your life
starts to suffer.
So the two things that are predictive,
one is really simple.
It's 21 hours a week.
That is the tipping point.
I've looked at all kinds of studies from,
you know,
people in the military too young,
like elementary school students.
Um,
21 hours a week.
When you go over that,
we start to see suffering and other aspects of life such as physical health,
mood,
your ability to do well at school or at work or other aspects of your life.
So three hours a day,
three hours a day aren't good,
but you could,
you could,
you know,
pile up on the weekend.
I mean,
it doesn't have to be.
Yeah.
Um,
and so I always say if you,
if you feel like you're addicted or you have a family member who you fear is
addicted,
do not take the games away because as you learn about reading the book,
Games are very powerful.
They,
they help treat or prevent depression.
And anxiety.
And if you take games away from somebody who's gaming 30,
40,
50,
60 hours a week,
you're basically like taking them off in antidepressant without tapering.
Um,
and we've seen a lot of people who,
uh,
I mean there's many cases of people committing suicide.
Young people when their parents have taken away the games and it's not just that
they're upset or angry,
it's literally their brain has had this powerful anti depressant ripped away
from them.
So,
so just go down to 20 hours a week.
Is that,
is that is one piece of practical advice for people who are really dealing with
addiction or compulsion.
Do not give it up.
Just get it down to 20 hours a week.
And that's actually very manageable for most people.
Even people who are feel like they,
they love to play.
They don't want to give up games.
You can get it down to three hours a day.
Um,
and uh,
so that's,
that is a practical tip.
Um,
but the other thing that predicts,
um,
negative outcomes or you're just not getting the benefits of games and real life
is looking at games as escapist.
So I was really interested to hear you say that,
you know,
you thought about games as escaping,
but you also maybe thought about them as a way to build these kinds of character
strengths.
Uh,
so it turns out the number one predictor of who will suffer from gameplay is who
think that games are an escape from real life or a way to avoid thinking about
or dealing with real problems.
People who manage to bring the game pull mindset and all the benefits to games
to the real lives are the people who identify benefits to game play and can talk
about them and can,
I can identify them and can say,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not just playing candy crush or call of duty because I just can't deal.
Like I just need to just shut everything off.
There are the people who say this is quality time,
you know,
for me and my brother and when we play this game together,
this is,
this is a real benefit to my life.
Or you know,
I'm playing this game because I'm having really anxious thoughts and I want to
shut them off.
And I know if I play this game for 10 minutes,
I can shut down.
I'm not going to have a panic attack.
So if you have a real purpose for how you play,
um,
that's when you start to build up the self efficacy to use a gainful strengths
in real life.
Now that that is not,
so you're asking like a very practical question,
like what should I do or what should I play it literally 10 to 20 minutes a day.
If you do 10 minutes every day or 20 minutes,
three times a week.
That's what's fantastic in clinical trials and randomized control studies to
have powerful impacts.
Um,
first and foremost on depression and anxiety,
improving your mood,
um,
for social interactions,
10 minutes a day,
um,
improves the number of people you have in your life who will help you with a
real life problem.
So I think of it,
it's just,
it's like,
you know,
I make time to do 10 pushups during every commercial of all the tennis that I
watched on TV.
Um,
so you should think about it that way.
Like,
how do you squeeze in a little bit of game play into your downtime that that
would,
so what type,
what I have to ask now of course,
since you mentioned it,
what,
what's on your top five game list or whatever that that just a,
a handful of your favorite games.
But then also for someone like me who doesn't want to get sucked into the
vortex,
yeah.
It feels like I should probably stay away from world's building games in that
case.
Yeah.
And maybe go with the cat more transactional kind of Tetris type of game or
something that allows me a closed short session.
Uh,
but what are,
what are some of your favorite games?
What are kind of on your,
your,
your hits list and then what might be games that I could use for those 10 to 20
minutes a day?
Yeah.
And what should my intention be going into them,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
um,
I'll just,
I mean,
when we don't do like an all time favorite games,
we'll just talk about,
because otherwise like I'd be like dance,
dance revolution totally on my top 10 all time,
but you know,
nobody plays it anymore.
Um,
but,
uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
Tetris is,
is definitely,
I mean everybody should have that on their phone because it treats so many
different conditions from anxiety to,
you know,
push my express order to,
building up your willpower.
So,
um,
Tetra is,
everybody should have tetris games at other people,
you know,
are playing is really,
really good.
Um,
and so this changes depending on the time.
So a lot of people are playing clash of clans right now,
um,
or candy crush saga or words with friends.
Um,
you should just check out what people that you know are playing because a lot of
the benefits that have been documented for games comes just from having these
sort of micro conversations with friends and family about the same game that
you're playing or actually playing in game with them.
So,
um,
any of those three games would be good.
I think Minecraft is really great,
even though it's like the most popular game of all time for kids now.
Um,
it's actually a really great resilience building game for grownups,
you know,
um,
because if,
if you're,
you know,
if you,
if you die,
if you have your stuff blown up and you have to kind of start over again,
um,
it has the qualities of the kind of game that we know builds resilience,
bills,
determination and willpower that can benefit you in real life.
So yeah,
if you,
I mean,
and by the way,
if somebody has not played Minecraft,
they've like missed out on one of the biggest cultural gifts you know,
of,
of our,
of our generation.
So that's me looking down at my feet right now,
so I'll get on it.
Okay.
So definitely do that.
So that because the next generation,
that's like all this going to be the number one nostalgia point.
Like all you're going to hear about 20 years from now or like people in their
twenties and thirties talking about Minecraft.
So it at least exposure herself.
Um,
and then I think puzzle games,
a single player puzzle games,
uh,
or a single player adventure games are really good for,
um,
provoking positive emotions at.
So portal is something I always recommend to people.
There's portal and portal two,
um,
it's incredibly challenging but hilarious a puzzle game that,
uh,
even though it's a,
the first one single player,
you can play the second one co op,
which is really cool.
In fact,
when I was playing portal too with my husband and we were also training for a
half marathon at that time,
we actually use our portal skills to better navigate like all the people that we
were trying to run around and pass a in the race.
We would,
we would use the same gesture,
all system that you use in the video game to communicate with each other.
Like how we were going to get around all of these people and still then come
back and run together.
Um,
so I the odd portal to that.
So,
uh,
yes,
those are some,
those are some good,
some good games to start with.
And,
um,
uh,
but,
but really any game that you love including,
I mean,
you could be playing pandemic,
the board game,
you could be playing poker.
I mean you could be playing,
um,
bridge or golf,
whatever.
Um,
most games,
even if they're not video games also help you develop that,
the gameful mindset.
And what is your,
I mean,
you clearly have,
you've got some babies,
get some dogs,
you got a husband,
you have at least one or several jobs.
Uh,
what is your sort of fed weekly,
let's just say this past week or next week,
what does the,
what does the workout schedule look like with the gaming?
Like what?
It's a,
yeah,
what is,
where do you,
where do you squeeze it in?
What time of day?
How many days a week?
Yeah.
Okay.
As well.
So first of all,
uh,
with two babies,
like I literally cannot play anything on a console now because I only had bass
have one hand,
like one thumb basically.
So,
uh,
we're talking strictly games on my phone.
Um,
and so for me,
candy crush saga,
it's the best one to be playing now because both my parents in law play and they
are helping us take care of our babies.
So,
you know,
when they come over,
uh,
I can give my father in law a baby to feed and I can take his phone and try to
get them off a level that's,
you know,
cause I'm like 400 levels ahead of him so I can,
take his phone and help him get off the level.
And now he's happy because he's a head of level and I'm happy cause he's feeding
the baby.
Um,
so,
so can't,
Eh,
for me that's actually really important.
Like using games I thought as a cultural touchstone or,
or piece of,
you know,
like common experience with,
with other people and my mom's also playing.
And so that's,
um,
that's really helpful.
And,
um,
then I also,
you know,
I played tennis with my husband once a week,
which is really good for me because if I lose six zero six,
one,
that is an amazing match for me.
Like I,
I won one game.
He's,
you know,
he's six foot three.
He's a dude.
He's like,
it's,
I guess
so CJ,
is he just like a hundred mile an airing or add that,
I don't know my numbers.
That might be slow.
I don't know.
But does that mean it's not,
that's it.
That's a good start.
No,
I mean,
is he just going to like being you as you go in for the kill or,
yeah,
I mean,
I finally just convinced him like the rear four weeks ago to serve such that I
could have returned.
Like literally he was,
it was,
it was like,
it was ridiculous.
But I,
my only points where like,
if you double faulted,
but,
um,
uh,
but so that,
that's a really good game from you that I play once a week because like,
I,
I'm kind of killing it in other areas of my life.
You know,
I feel like very successful in other areas of my life and I think getting
clobbered,
uh,
once a week in a game that I'm very bad at.
Um,
and they'll just think this,
this is documented to be true.
If you can take the collaborating and stay optimistic and still have positive
emotions throughout that experience,
it builds a lot of psychological resources that you will be able to draw on when
it's not a game,
but when it's real life.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
okay.
So I'm getting clobbered in tennis once a week.
Which day of the week?
What time of day?
I love the specifics.
Like how,
how many a week,
how many days per week you playing candy crush saga and then what day of the
week on tennis?
Yeah.
Uh,
candidates.
Okay.
The question is every day and uh,
you know,
uh,
what I would say,
I probably look at it,
you know,
twice a day.
Um,
maybe in the morning I make sure to spin the wheel to get my free power up.
I might not play it,
but I'm like,
I don't want to forget to get cause every day and candy crush you'd get one free
power,
but otherwise they charge you like,
you know,
99 cents for it.
Um,
so I make sure,
even like when I'm traveling and giving talks and other countries and have no
time for anything,
I always log in once a day and spend to get,
so I can have like the stash of power ups for when I want to really hard level.
Um,
so I do that in the morning and then later in the evening,
um,
I'll,
uh,
I will do it.
Um,
uh,
I find it's actually good for me before I go to sleep because I have one of
those minds that will anxiously race about all the things that I have to do
tomorrow.
Um,
and uh,
so we know,
uh,
there's a,
there's a set of quests and power ups and bad guys for insomnia in,
in super better.
And,
uh,
so I know one of the tricks for that,
one of the ways you battle the bad guy of,
um,
of the sort of ruminating on things you have to do tomorrow is to totally occupy
your brain with something else for 10 minutes.
So I find that to be a good kind of nightcap for me.
That's a great idea.
Maybe that's how I get my tetris because I've used fiction for that,
but sometimes I just don't have the concentration.
Uh,
kitchen.
and then the tennis is on
tennis is on Sunday afternoons and uh,
yeah,
that's when we get,
we get our,
uh,
his parents babysit for us and we go,
yeah.
So get it on the calendar.
People listening,
he can't just improvise your way through the entire week.
It's very helpful to get on the calendar.
Yeah.
Let me ask a handful of last questions.
I know that,
uh,
I want to be respectful of your time and make sure that your,
your kids aren't climbing up out the window sills or something,
but,
uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
Oh my goodness.
Um,
I've heard you ask that question to someone else too and they were totally
stumped too.
Um,
I think,
uh,
okay,
wait,
I was going to say Bill Gates,
which first of all is very boring.
Um,
and also it's a man and I really want to answer a woman.
So I'm going to,
because I,
that's something I spend a lot of time doing,
like making sure that I don't accidentally talk only about successful men.
Even in my book,
like,
you know,
a lot of,
I make sure I'm citing a lot of women scientists because,
um,
it's oftentimes the first person we think of as a man because they're so often
talked about more so.
Okay.
I like to say,
um,
I think of Elizabeth War and was actually the next name,
uh,
that came to mind.
Senator Elizabeth Warren because I think she is doing an job of,
um,
pushing back against powerful interests in this country and getting us to talk
about,
um,
making big changes to,
uh,
to our financial system and our political system.
And it's really hard for anybody to get any traction in that,
in this country today.
So that was who I thought of.
And maybe that's,
it's actually,
it might be wishful thinking because I would love to see her run for president.
So maybe I'm,
maybe I'm using my futurist forecasting skills here to think that,
you know,
in 2024,
she has just successfully been elected president and that's why I thought of her
as the most successful person I could think of.
Cross your fingers,
everybody.
Okay.
Nostradamus in fact,
speaking of successful women,
uh,
there are a number of exercises in the beginning of super better and I did
actually go through these exercises,
uh,
including the,
the quests I should say.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I actually did both of these,
so I was in a coffee shop and one of the most,
you know,
stand up and take three steps or make your hands into fists,
hold them over your head as high as you can for five seconds.
So I did both in this coffee shop.
Totally.
I get humor and I,
and I,
I pretended to be stretching because it is,
it turns out five seconds.
It's pretty long.
Yes it is.
But I love these,
these comfort challenges.
And then there was the,
for instance,
the snapping of the fingers exactly 50 times.
And these very,
very small things,
looking out the window for certain periods of time and so on that I've found
really fun to do.
Even as comfort challenges.
I just enjoy anything that,
that allows you to practice being uncomfortable.
But,
uh,
how it,
so all right.
The line that struck me was I've watched some amazing people complete the same
four questions are about to undertake,
including Oprah Winfrey,
legendary skateboarder and entrepreneur,
Tony Hawk,
and then it goes on.
So,
okay.
How did,
how did you get Oprah to do these exercises?
Right.
That was a long story.
I actually,
um,
uh,
I was,
I was on tour with,
with Oprah on her life class a show,
not actually doing anything,
um,
on stage with her,
but,
um,
I was,
uh,
we,
we created a game together,
um,
called the thank you game.
Oprah's thank you game.
And it was a game designed to spread gratitude to as many people as possible
because gratitude is contagious and it has all these amazing life and health
benefits.
Um,
and so,
so I,
I made a game for her.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I'll,
somewhere along the way,
I mean,
I had gotten a phone call from people,
uh,
from her people who had,
they'd stumbled across,
um,
some scientific research and then they saw my name associated with it.
And I mean,
I just got very lucky that,
um,
that her and her team were kind of suddenly interested in end games and gainful
psychology.
And it was the first time I met her,
uh,
I had meetings with her team like a dozen times,
and,
uh,
I was like in a conference room and she comes in and gives me a big hug and
says,
I love you.
Which was like having,
I basically look at her,
it's happening,
like saved my life as a kid.
I watched her every day after school and like,
she really,
I felt like it was going to therapy,
watching her show.
Sure.
I thought,
yeah,
yeah.
And I was like,
I cannot like literally her saying,
I love you.
I felt like I could have died on the spot and like my life would have had a full
karmic circle.
Like I was totally okay with that.
Um,
and,
uh,
but we just started talking about the power of games and I,
I said,
uh,
you know,
let me show you the game that I'm working on now.
And uh,
and had her and,
and,
and I didn't know she was going to actually do it and play along.
And she did and it was freaking awesome.
Um,
and uh,
and that,
that,
that led into making the,
the Oprahs thank you game where we spread gratitude.
I think it was like how many people did we get to?
It was,
it was like over a hundred million people,
which is
people like,
oh yeah,
just another hundred million people.
Incredible.
Uh,
what is the book that you've given most often as a gift or any books that
you've,
a lot as gifts?
Um,
there are two.
one is,
uh,
called finite and infinite games,
which is by a professor of religious studies,
uh,
in New York University named James Carse.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's basically a book about games,
but then it turns out it's about the meaning of life.
You don't know until the last page.
It's like this big shock.
It's like 6 cents that you thought you were reading a book about games.
And then suddenly it's like,
yeah,
the last,
the last line of the book is there is but one infinite game.
And then you're like,
oh shit,
it's life.
Life is the infinite game.
Um,
and uh,
so that's a,
it's like a really easy,
it's a tiny,
tiny block.
It's like practically a pocket book.
So anyone is interested in philosophy,
um,
and looking at games as,
as a way of life.
That's a really good one.
Um,
and then,
uh,
a book,
um,
uh,
well,
it's a,
it's called suffering is optional actually.
Um,
so in is by my favorite Buddhist teacher,
Cheri Huber and uh,
it,
so that is,
I,
I'm,
I'm very inspired by Buddhist practices.
I mean,
I,
I practiced Zen Buddhism myself and,
um,
uh,
this was,
I think that game play and Buddhist practice or both a way to arrive at a
similar approach to life.
Um,
and so,
uh,
that's,
that's another good book.
What was her last name?
Huber.
Hub.
E.
R.
Awesome.
She has an amazing podcast too,
by the way.
So if,
if people who love your podcast,
they can listen to her podcast too
interviewed,
I'm not if you know the name
Tara Brock,
but uh,
she's,
she's an amazing teacher and focuses on mindfulness and Buddhist teachings and
so on.
Just fantastic.
And I think that this has been a really interesting week for me because it's
tying together a bunch of seemingly disparate activities.
So you have the say Buddhist philosophy and teaching.
Then you have stoic philosophy of course,
which I've read a ton of and just a huge fan of whether it's Seneca,
Marcus Aurelius or others.
And then you have the game play and they,
they seem,
they serve very similar.
They can help you achieve very similar outcomes.
Uh,
it's very fascinating.
do you have a favorite documentary?
Any favorite documentaries?
Oh,
well I have to plug a documentary called Gamers,
which uh,
with me,
it in 2003,
I think.
And it was the first full length feature documentary about competitive video
game players.
At the time it was the cyber athlete professional league,
the Cpl.
Now,
of course you've got like League of legends finals,
like more people attended,
bought a ticket and attended league of legends finals and the Stanley Cup finals
this year.
Um,
so,
but this is from 2003 and it's available in its entirety on Youtube.
Um,
so you can just like watch it for free.
and that was uh,
that was a fascinating documentary that I think,
uh,
as as the years pass and competitive video gaming becomes even more a part of
our mainstream athletic lives.
Um,
that,
that early look at it is pretty damn cool.
Have you seen King of Kong?
Of course.
Okay.
All right.
That's in the movie theater.
The day I came out.
God,
King of Kong you want to talk about like old school mullet vengeance,
retro video game competitions.
So amazing.
So yeah,
for I will definitely check out gamers and for people who haven't seen King of
Kong,
it seems like a spinal tap sort of parity like a mockumentary.
It is such a hilarious,
so such a well done documentary
at people take game seriously,
which is,
that's one of the great paradoxes of play,
right,
is that it's only play if it's not serious except then we take it incredibly
seriously,
which is,
uh,
which is good because that unlocks all of our gainful strengths.
What,
uh,
what,
just a few more questions.
What purchase of less than a hundred dollars has most positively impacted your
life in the last,
say six to 12 months?
Oh my gosh.
Um,
I would say,
well this is so,
I mean this is not going to be surprising at all,
but I would say a Bjorn carrier for the babies.
Um,
so,
uh,
we,
we live on a hill and every day we take the babies out for an hour long walk,
half an hour,
you know,
trudging up this really steep hill,
uh,
and coming back down and uh,
being able to leave the house and get some fresh air.
Um,
and also a great workout because the babies are getting fatter every day.
So it's like,
like just,
just when you're getting really fit,
walking up the hill,
the baby weighs is another pound and you're,
you know,
so I would say my Bjorn carrier.
And now is that like a,
a strap that attaches,
said fat babies to you or is that
yeah,
it's like a harness that you,
it goes around your back and then the baby like kind of hugs your chest.
Ah,
cool.
B.
Why BJ?
Bj.
O.
R.
N.
Yeah.
Br.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
you know,
the babies,
this is a,
this is progressive resistance for moms.
It's kind of like the story of,
I think it's mellow or Milo of Crotona who,
who every day had to pick up a baby bull calf and lifted over a fence.
And then of course the story goes,
you know,
what,
as became a larger and larger bully became the strongest,
strongest men in the world.
Yes.
And this is such a great way to tie back to video games because the,
one of the reasons why video games are tend to be even better for your gameful
mindset then other games is that they always get harder,
right?
There's a right depressive for this adaptive,
So you're,
it's like not like chess where it's very hard to find somebody who's just
slightly better than you every single time you play.
Um,
this is video games are designed to be that kind of progressive resistance.
So you're always playing at the edge of your ability,
therefore always getting better.
Such a,
such an important point.
I'm really glad you brought that,
brought that up.
Uh,
what morning rituals do you are?
What,
what morning rituals are important to you?
Um,
I said I'm a terrible person,
so I will confess.
I,
okay.
So there's a neuroscience hack in here.
So when I wake up,
I basically like put on tennis like,
like today's whatever the latest,
like last 24 hour tennis matches are on TV.
I'm constantly recording on the tennis channel or Espn,
the live tennis.
Um,
and,
uh,
and then I,
I do email while I'm watching tennis and,
um,
I spent an inordinate amount of time watching friends.
Like when I started my startup company for super better,
I would like disappear for eight hours to go watch,
you know,
the French Open live.
Like that was just,
you know,
part of my,
uh,
that's,
that's working with Jane is she will go disappear and watch tennis for,
you know,
eight hours a day for two to three weeks stretches.
Um,
but,
but it's a good neuroscience hack because all is this true for all professional
sports.
Um,
every time you make a prediction about something,
your brain increases the amount of dopamine that it has access to because it
anticipates either success,
you've successfully predicted what would happen.
So that's great.
Or You'll learn from your mistakes.
So you'll learn information that will make you have a better prediction next
time.
And every time you get a little boost of dopamine,
it's like,
it's like taking amphetamines,
right?
So I like to start my day with watching a tennis match because I will have a
prediction about who I think will win.
And then I will either be right or wrong and I will either feel awesome that I
was right or I will learn something about how somebody is playing right now and
what their game is like right now and,
and I'll make a better prediction next time.
And so it's like,
it's like basically,
you know,
it's like a really strong cup of coffee or taking an amphetamine,
um,
giving my brain that kind of a boost,
uh,
every morning.
But you can any,
you know,
any,
if you have a sports team that you like,
that's why people who are really in professional sports,
um,
are happier during the sports season.
Then off season,
it's not just that they missed their favorite game is that their brain is
constantly anticipating success for their favorite team,
which is uh,
increasing dopamine.
So I like tennis because they only have one month off all year.
They play for 11 months.
The season is incredibly long.
You can get your fix
is it has there,
I wasn't expecting me to ask this question,
but now that you mentioned watching tennis,
I love watching tennis mesmerized by it.
And it's true for a handful of,
of,
uh,
individual sports like gymnastics.
Also,
same story.
Uh,
is there any,
have any studies been conducted looking at the carryover benefits of observing
game play as opposed to being involved in that yourself?
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
So,
um,
because,
but it only works if you know how to play the game yourself.
Um,
and if you know how to play the game,
you activate mirror neuron.
So,
um,
I have found it if I've,
if it's during Wimbledon or the French Open,
it's a US Open.
I've been watching literally eight hours a day for two weeks.
Um,
I will go on the court that Sunday and play better because,
because I know how to play tennis and my brain can physically embody,
like if I see somebody going for a point,
my body and my brain understands what that feels like.
And so it creates a mirror neuron effect.
So it's practicing.
Um,
so if you have never played the game or sport yourself,
like watching gymnastics is not going to do a lot for you unless you have
physically been on the mat or on the rings or the bars and you know what it
feels like.
Um,
but if you know what it feels like,
then your brain practices while you play and it actually is beneficial and that
that has been documented.
So,
um,
if you want to get the benefits of watching a sport,
you should make sure you played it enough times that your,
your body can,
your brain can follow along in that year in our own way.
So that that brings up all sorts of interesting ideas such as,
for instance,
if you knew that if I knew I was going to have a surgery that was going to take
me out of commission from a sports standpoint for three to six months,
I'm just making that up.
If I didn't know how to play tennis,
I could do like a three day intensive or two day intensive immersion course for
tennis and then use watching tennis therapeutic therapeutically when I'm laid
out for the subsequent period of time.
You are so good at this.
I love the way your brain like,
I think that is such an awesome and extreme idea and I really think you and I
write a book together.
Sometime we should take,
like all of that would be,
that would be something new and interesting and you could take all of this
research to that extreme,
really life maximizing level in ways that I would never think about.
Gee,
yes,
I agree.
Uh,
the,
I keep on saying a few more questions.
Five more minutes took ish snatch.
But anyway,
the uh,
if you had a billboard you could put anywhere it could say anything,
what would it say and where would you put it?
Oh my God.
Um,
I will,
I would get a billboard that says,
uh,
I mean I really want to do a public service announcement about tetris.
You know,
I would,
I would about how tetris can prevent post traumatic stress disorder and I would
put it,
you know,
uh,
I don't know where I would,
you should put it in games.
Really.
I should,
cause you know,
you can like buy advertising in video games.
So I should have,
I should have a billboard in,
in video games.
Uh,
so that people who are open to this idea of games and playing them and
benefiting from them because they,
I,
it really makes me agitated that there is so much good research that would have
such profound,
I mean,
the difference between getting PJC and not getting PTSD and what that would have
on your life is so freaking profound that,
uh,
I really feel like a,
I would like to,
I'd like to get in people's faces about that.
So,
you know,
10,
10 minutes of Tetris after a trauma done.
Right.
That's my billboard.
I love it.
And I mean,
I want to play with Tetra side.
I grew up playing tetris on the game boy,
so it doesn't take a lot to twist my arm to get back into it.
Uh,
but I heard a phrase recently which was a take on PTSD,
but it was related to worrying about things.
So having anxiety about what might happen and they,
and uh,
it was called a pre traumatic stress disorder.
And I wonder,
uh,
I'll,
I'll do some experimentation and report back to you,
but I wonder if tetras could have an inoculating effect against experiencing
trauma or even foreseeing trauma because you would imagine since that worrying
is a visual,
often a visualization,
it might have the same type of,
of a kind of decoupling or for coupling effect that minimizes the,
the negative,
I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Well,
as you get further in the book,
you'll see actually it's super Mario that's been tested,
um,
for basically exactly that thing,
sort of prevent the predictive anxiety,
um,
better than anti anxiety medicine.
I need to play more games that,
that is clear and it's such a nice day.
I think I want to go whack a tennis ball around.
So,
uh,
if you could make one ask of the people listening or recommendation aside from
of course the book and I'm going to,
I will put everything in the show notes,
but what ask or recommendation would you make of the people listening?
I would encourage people to ask one person in their life what is their favorite
game and it could be any kind of game to them to a video game and what it is,
um,
that they think that gay makes them good at.
Because one of the things that I found in my research is the best way to ensure
that somebody starts to use their game full strengths in real life is to talk
about what games they play and what those games make them good at.
So if we could have everybody ask one person that question,
not only will you learn something really interesting about someone you care
about,
but they will also benefit from now starting to think about their game,
full strengths and then maybe how they might apply them in real life.
Well Jane,
dear you and I should get together and a scheme like pinky and the brain to come
up with some type of massive experiment.
I love it.
Yeah,
we should,
we should definitely make that happen.
This is a,
this is really fun Jane.
Where can people find out everything about you and learn more about super better
and also say hi to you on a Twitter,
Facebook or wherever you might be active.
Yeah,
I'm super active on Twitter.
I'm at Vons Game,
a v a n t game,
but you just search for my name.
Um,
my website's Jane mcgonigal.com,
but I have another site that I think everybody who listens to you like,
which is show me the science.com where I collect all of the studies that back up
all of the things that I'm encouraging people to do it with games.
So,
and you can actually get the full academic article if you're a geek like me and
read it.
And so,
you know,
you don't have to take my word for it.
Um,
everything that I've said in the book I have,
I've literally a thousand studies online that you can click through to and read
yourself so that you can be a geek like me.
So it show me the science,
like,
show me the money,
show me the money you just brought up all sorts of visuals for me.
Cuba Gooding Jr dance around with his shirt off,
play Tetris,
the block,
the imagery.
Well Jane,
it's always so much fun to hang out virtually or in person.
We need to hang out more.
Everybody listening,
check out.
Super better.
A revolutionary approach to getting stronger,
happier,
braver and more resilient.
I am stoked to go play some more games.
I'm going to do that today and make it happen.
And uh,
everybody's listening.
Show notes,
links,
everything will be@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast all spelled out.
So you build to find links to everything.
And Jane,
thank you so much for taking the time.
Thank you.
You're awesome.
You're one of my heroes.
So this is really amazing to get to do
well.
I feel the same about you.
So we will,
we will,
we will go hatch some plans and everybody thank you so much for listening and
until next time,
game on.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim
episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my gosh,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me.
It just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body,
and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash.
Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay.